Simmons bike twice as a possible third
time
but there's a certain amount of em
having a shaming towards Speicher
I don't accept drinks from strangers I
watched the way to pour my drink I hold
my hand over my drink at all times I
actually kicked the door in
she was lying on the floor she her eyes
rolled into her head she couldn't speak
if I got older them I'd strangle him I
really would
that may well be drink spiking reports
to police forces across the UK have
doubled in three years I want to know
what drugs are used in spiking attacks
why people do it and what effect it has
on people's lives dizzy can you walk me
through the first time the u.s. vibes it
was actually my first time going to like
a bougie like fancy like London club I
never wear heels really and they were
like slightly too big at the back the
only place in this club where you could
sit down was the tables and so there was
these two guys this one table these guys
like just to sit down while I raped my
friends in the bathroom drinks came
along and I don't normally accept drinks
from strangers but because it was like a
bottle service so a race' was pouring
the drink for me I was like okay that's
fine I keep an eye on my drinks but at
some point in the night obviously
something was put through my fingers and
I was spiked so my friend couldn't find
me I went missing for a bit of night and
he was looking for me I wasn't answering
my phone a bouncer said your friend has
been spiked and someone else is taking I
to a taxi my friend was confused cuz it
was only those two and he was like war
friends went looking for me down an
alleyway by the club and this guy is
strange man and I was sitting a table
where they're trying to put me into a
cab
now found talking to victims afterwards
when I've been doing testing they rack
the brains they're worried about it they
they're very very anxious they can't
remember it really changes their life
and they need an answer really what kind
of drugs are being used in spiking
attacks they vary a lot I mean the
traditional one is rohypnol there are
lots of benzodiazepines lots of
different tablets you can buy these on
the internet you can use GHB you can use
a whole range of things right through to
now LSD mostly they make people feel
really drowsy especially with alcohol
and they become quite compliant
this video shows Lauren Collins after
her drink was spiked at Leeds Festival
in 2017 she thinks a man put drugs in
her drink after he approached her for a
lighter within 20 minutes she'd vomited
and passed out her husband took this
video when they were back in their tent
and he gave her first aid Lauren says
the incident still gives her anxiety and
she hasn't been out drinking much since
I asked dizzy why she thinks spiking
attacks happen I think sometimes it's to
rape I think sometimes it's for
amusement I think sometimes just to I
don't people must get some kind of
thrill out of it I guess because it
happens so much I don't think it's fair
to say it's my fault for accepting a
drink from someone who's fighting
there's no power and I think the men
that goes to these clubs are very
wealthy they paid thousands of pounds to
be there and girls Allah and a lot
cheaper there's more of that kind of
just like possession of women
this video shows an alleged spiking
caught on camera at a festival in Brazil
watch The Woman's cup luckily the woman
realized she'd been spiked when she
watched back this selfie
I think the reporting of this offence in
particular is massively and reported at
the moment
obviously it causes me great concern now
what I will say is in a lot of cases
where spiking offences have been either
suspected or reported to the police
often it is the case that they've
actually been spiked but it's not with
any sort of illegal substance it's with
alcohol so if you believe you're
drinking a pint of lager for instance it
may be that you are but somebody's added
a spirit of vodka or something like that
that has no smell and that could be in
your drink so it could be spiked but it
could actually just be spanked with
alcohol rather than an illegal substance
if you could talk to someone that's
that's spiked drinks in the past what
could you say for now I turn around and
tell them do they really know what
they're doing at the end of the day they
actually could kill somebody if I got
older them I'd strangle them
I really would because these people are
just lowlife tell me about what you've
seen I actually went to the ladies
toilet because a friend wasn't looking
for her
I actually kicked the door in she was
lying on the floor unconscious but
looking at her from my experience I knew
that she'd been spiked she her eyes
rolled into her head she couldn't speak
she didn't know where she was she didn't
know how she got there so I stayed with
her got the door staff to ring an
ambulance and the police and I contacted
her mother to let her know that she
wasn't coming home that night that she
was going straight to hospital because
she'd been spiked you say it happened so
much how many of your friends you think
of in spite oh I couldn't even I think
it's yeah too many too many I think
I'd say fewer have him from spikes than
have been it's a lot more common I think
then people expect well I've had a case
that I've heard of I wasn't personally
involved but the analysis of a urine
sample didn't show anything she was
convinced absolutely convinced that
something had happened to her and she
took her own life in the finish the
drugs back in the 80s and 90s there was
just fun drugs that people use attack
just to be happy the obviously dealers
and the drug makers have made it
profitable that they can actually do
this and destroy somebody destroy their
life sadly the cases that are reported
to us are because they end in a serious
sexual offense I believe there are
probably occasions where people believe
they may have been spiked because of got
home safely or somebody's taken care of
them and looked after them
that fence doesn't get reported because
nothing happened most of my friends have
been spiked so at the time I didn't
think of it was that big of a deal to
report and I was almost like what are
they gonna do so I was okay I got away
safely it's to be honest I think if
you're going to spike someone you have
some psychological issues it can ruin
their life they go through day to day
they remember it it's missing look and
shake off they've got to live with it
there may well be deaths from having
something put in drink that aren't in
the public eye very dangerous
[Music]